oh wait did she be just raid us why is the font slave raid oh thank you for the raid
she be oh right welcome she's here how did she be stream go I think I think
I noticed she was also playing some sort of scary game right I couldn't tell it
was something bunny bunny something right don't say slavery but isn't that
your slaves are reading I'm reading the stream are they not your slaves or
bunny came yeah oh that's on brand for her she muted a guy that said he was a
diamond went mad with power why would anyone why would any Dom enter she be
stream that's just asking to get slapped across the face that's asking to get
hung by your balls hi hi welcome welcome we say read what are we what do you mean
what are we according to she be your hair and your hair and or her slaves
mods testicular torsion mods I cast a stick your torsion on you okay I'm
currently waiting for poppy playtime to finish downloading I thought I had it
installed already but apparently I didn't I think because it's a DLC it
didn't transfer because I'm family sharing with my other account so I guess
I had to have to download it again let's see now I'm playing chapter 2 because
I've already played chapter 1 and wait oh fuck it's on my speakers let me close
the game yeah I already I already played chapter 1 so yeah that's why I'm playing
chapter 2 chapter 1 was a fucking mess yes I'm still feeling sick for some
reason my my audio help put device
yes try that again also I want to say thank you for all the nice marshmallows
I've gotten I really really want to answer every single one I don't know if I'll
get to it but I really really want to try just give me some time okay chapter 2
and 3 are so much better are they oh god that's loud okay let me adjust some stuff
first so brightness all the way up okay mostly up music down sounds down
okay
I think that should be that should be good I prefer 2 and 3 okay okay okay well
then we'll see I was like when I say one was bad I mean like I fucking failed
at every single puzzle that's what I mean oh thank you for all the orange hearts
thank you as long as they make you smile that's all that counts oh okay okay
let me move to a different screen is that capturing good nope nope nope oh that
is not capturing good okay are you okay if I have like a random gap I don't know
why maybe I can change the resolution to be better I don't know why that gap is
there I see is totally more of a brat than me I am not as much of a brat as
she is you like cats or maybe full-screen would make it gapless oh oh but
now every time I click I always have trouble with this game oh there we go
now it's gapless wait why am I floating am I floating for anyone every time I
click back on to I'm so confused okay I'm just gonna make it windowed and
there's just gonna be a gap or borderless window no there's just gonna be a gap oh
well whatever whatever it's okay sorry I know the music keeps pausing because I
keep clicking off at the game you're not late you're not late we haven't even started yet
okay um okay I think we can start the resolution the red that resolution is
very wait let is something wrong with the resolution right now
is it okay I just do regular windowed
no you can see my fucking no borderless one looks good looks good okay okay okay okay
did you intend it to be 1280 times 720 this I can make it higher no what's the highest
here what's the highest resolution here this is a higher resolution
gonna be cushing every time I scream oh my god most monitors are 1920 by 1080 I have
really weird monitors because both of my monitors are really old so it's really
possible that they're that they're like strangely shaped wait this is a high
resolution I don't understand resolutions we'll just get there just gonna keep it at
this I'm just gonna keep it at that okay okay okay okay or should I make it should
I make it in the middle like that yeah yeah that's good that's good okay okay
let's play okay chapter 2 okay as long as it looks good to you it looks good to me I
think I think okay so with Poppy now free the situation begins to change rapidly while
you search for any way to escape the factory new game I haven't played a game
before the game looks good now but you look it's mommy long legs
oh my god she's just like me you can stretch pull and twist me in the craziest ways too
the new mommy long legs from playtime co what's the time playtime oh no
wait that's the doll isn't it yeah that's that's is that Poppy I'm like okay get ready
to cringe this is gonna be rough I don't I think I saw one playthrough of chapter 2 so okay
first things first we're gonna turn our brightness even higher I don't like little
brightness I like to see what the fuck is going on in my game okay one more thing I
want to okay max gamma listen I like to see where the fuck I'm going okay
if it looks bad I'm sorry can I pick these up bring them with me for comfort no
yeah in me gaming you're gonna learn really quick why why don't game you're gonna learn real fast
why doesn't it how do I get out of here oh I probably have to I'm guessing I probably have
to figure it out myself don't I it's a puzzle game okay also backseating is totally okay with me
if you want to backseat me please do I don't know how to get out of here already can I just
well can I just jump parkour it yeah if anyone knows how to play this game please help oh there's
wait I already saw that door authentic Alzheimer's experience here go down the red
hallway wait there's another hallway wait I was just here though secret bookies did I miss
something here no one tell her no please tell me please tell me floating head huh okay let me
change my vtube studio I change my vtube studio a hotkey from my head none there okay there
there there it's fixed um my immersion oh no you're not really an anime girl how do I get out
of here someone said secret bookcase do I click on a book in here no and someone help me you're
right it's the door oh wait II I forgot I forgot I could click that okay wait we were in this hallway
before in chapter one weren't we we go over here I forgot that the controls I haven't played
chapter one in a long time I'm sorry to lie to you anime is not real your waifu is not real
it's just me I'm the only one that's real only in me is real no one else exists why is there
blood on this toy your entire life is a lie I guess this is the only direction I can go do you
want collections what do you mean collections I just heard a sound I should probably have both
of my headphones on for this didn't I I just like to hear myself talk I love to hear myself yeah
do I have to figure out how to get past here and I run in this game
how do I we like to hear you you have to fuck okay wait wait I didn't think I'd figure it out
so quickly I'm so smart oh my god wait do I have to run yeah yeah let me cook let me cook I'm
getting there I'm getting there how do I do this am I letting go too soon and too late oh
there we go oh there's another buddy toy here oh my god I have a story about this okay can I bring
this with me no when I was in kindergarten I used to they used to have dinosaur toys in
kindergarten and my favorite dinosaur toy was the long neck dinosaur toy and I played with it
all the time and that was the only dinosaur toy I played with and anytime you know any other kid
wanted the long neck one I wouldn't let them have it because it was my toy and then this one kid
wanted the long neck dinosaur toy but I didn't want to give it to him because it was my freaking
toy and so he didn't even want it because he wanted to play with it he just wanted it because
he knew I liked it have to you in the inventory oh okay he just wanted it because I liked it and he
wanted to like you know take it from me and so when I told him no he was like Amy's a bully he
started teasing me and he made a whole song of it buttons are there other buttons other than E
he made a whole song with lyrics about how I was a bully and he would sing it to me oh wait press
here okay puppy oh wait you're not puppy what's your name what's his name again um I forgot his
name was it catchy no right how dare they bully me huggy wuggy huggy wuggy yeah there you go huggy
look at me I'm right at the perfect height for him okay um then we come from there I feel like I
should have done I mean I guess I got a key from this room right maybe I shouldn't have made it maybe
there's nothing more to do here for the next place is there another place wait there was a door
that was locked wasn't there you have to have to fucking do this again okay I did it I'm doing so
well compared to other times how do I run okay this door I wish I was as tall as Hucky you
don't even need to be as tall as Hucky don't worry I'm short enough or you don't need to be as tall
um I'm guessing I have to put a cassette in there oh look at all the drawings on him oh
so good what is that I need to find a cassette in here don't they more bloody toys more drawings
my best friend oh my god literally me and my long neck dinosaur toy oh thank you mr. Ludwig wait is
that a reference to the actual streamer wait you didn't have to swing again there was a ramp oh yeah
you're right I could have just felt fell down if you're as tall as huggy the NBA would be the most
realistic true what does this one say for Elliott Ludwig wait I don't think it's actually the
streamer Ludwig is it it's probably a character I can't read that hey we made toys like this in
the first chapter okay give me the freaking cassette oh there's a note here no give me the
give me the cassette next next give me the cassette huh I'm not the cassette fuck give me the note
help me only chance experiment 814 notes this experiment utilized a live rat rat was fed
three portions daily for two weeks at the end of the two weeks the rat was killed are you fucking
kidding me they knew I was playing this game they wanted to torture me into a poppy flower and
preserve preservative gel mixture one week later an electric shock was applied to the rat
still in the gel and attempt to revive it the rat remained unresponsive of course it fucking
remained unresponsive you should have been it should have been me not the rat it should
have been me just take me don't take the rat analysis I still believe in the potential of
the poppy flower its unusual properties lead me to believe that the proper mixture and procedure
could have life-altering properties the poppy flower has for a long time carried heavy symbolism
and I don't believe that's for bro this guy's got terrible grammar and I don't believe that's
for no reason perhaps something larger than a rat would yield different results yeah I don't
think so let's watch this play can I zoom in somehow I feel like I'm too sure is the product
of a great man by the name of Elliot Ludwig divorced but a family man his site will always
set on bringing amazing toys to amazing children around the globe Ludwig spent countless hours
in the factory working overtime relentlessly in an attempt to continuously innovate and surprise
in the 1960s an unfortunate family death had pushed Ludwig down to his lowest but with so
much ambition he rose back up and continued to fulfill his vision for the playtime code
why do they censor his face Ludwig could never be content leaving a project unfinished but
just how did one man come to create such an astounding empire how did he manage to stay
determined even after suffering such a tragic loss it all began in the fateful year of 19
oh I guess that's all okay okay not the streamer Ludwig can we get up here I feel
like this is someplace I should look into okay maybe not he's probably disfigured oh you think
something happened to him when does William Afton come in wrong game wrong game I'm William Afton
maybe oh wait am I supposed to go in there no I'm not right I remember watching Markiplier
play chapter 2 and he streamed it and he refused to look at chat to help him and he got stuck for
like two fucking hours in one part of the game because he's too fucking stupid to like even I
knew what to do and I'm really stupid and I don't want that to happen to you guys I don't want
you to get like super frustrated with me playing this game there's another vent
come down oh okay thank you okay thank you oh my I hope another huggy-wuggy doesn't come and chase me
this was literally the room that he got stuck in isn't it oh careful what you wish for what
you mean oh you think he's actually coming I thought he's not in this chapter I'm safe hell you
should it's Wendy's friend what's Wendy from Wendy's I actually had Wendy's today I had a rusty
chino oh I'm not doing this right am I when now oh oh I didn't even see this one I was trying to
get to that okay okay did I do it did I do it did I do you're welcome she sounds just like me
good job thank you oh get on up here okay I have to figure out a way to get up there huh okay okay
okay I'm coming twinsy please shut up you're distracting me close this stop teasing me I'm
trying okay
any playtime there's a bar to grab above the vent pull up um okay maybe I'm going
the wrong direction above this one this is exactly how Markiplier got stuck fuck look up
where the vent is okay here's the vent there's a colored part of the bar your poppy no you
just missed it colored what the fuck she's up there oh I didn't even see her wait so I go up
here then vent I came from bring me up now oh do I just go up here grab the golden flower
figurine okay I go up here wait was there a golden flower figurine here though you got it you
oh in the office I was supposed to take it oh well maybe if I go back if we ever go back I'll take
it I'm doing good thank you it's a collectible oh I don't really care oh we're back here okay
there we go I see you oh god you're fucking creepy well how do I get up there now are we doing
the collectibles I mean if you see one is this one a collectible no if you see one you can point
it out and I'll try to get it but I don't really care too much okay now she said this way but we
can't go that way door okay door oh this door I'm so smart oh my god bro I'm gonna be doing I'm
gonna be doing a math stream you'll see soon I don't want to spoil it and oh my god it's gonna be so
embarrassing someone someone sent me a marshmallow asking if I have this calculus I don't think I do
I don't think I do I've I used to be able to do math really good it's just I've always been bad with
simple numbers well I've just always been bad with numbers in general but like I'm still able to do
it I just can't like I don't know it's it's like I don't know how to explain it I'm like you like
I'm coming for you don't worry I'll save you puppy cute girls gotta stick together I'll get you don't
worry I'll save you was I not supposed to jump a lot of people die a couple times on that big gap
you went over what gap yeah exactly that's what calculators are for that's why I took out a calculator
in the last stream to you know calculate no hesitation nice of course I was gonna save me
you're gonna save me you're gonna save me right I don't know which way to go but I'll go this way
first oh fuck I hate these I hate these I hate these cuz can I just do this wait what
of course we will thank you no one left behind yeah you always have a calculator in real life
that's what I'm saying I never understood why they didn't let us have like when I was in elementary
school they didn't let us have calculators during tests but then as soon as I got into high school
they always let us have a calculator like oh fuck they always let us have a calculator
and I was so confused why we weren't allowed to have them
grab the one from the left side
I'm like doing it wrong
you see the blue pipe what if you got it from an angle
what
to make sure you were able to do calculations manually I guess well I'm still not able to do it
manually what do I wrap it around like this you can work this out I really can't I was
stuck on these ones a lot in chapter in chapter one
something like that that's why you got Rick brother to help you with math yeah you're gonna
help me with math soon you'll see I'm very confused blue pipe right pull
blue pipe right pull
no I don't know what you mean by wrap it around the blue pipe I don't know how to
you started the correct position but got the second bar before the first freaking line
what if you get it from that first thing we'll avoid it the whole and then went to the other side
okay
fuck oh this is not gonna end well um
start on the left walk way and walk to the right walk way okay I'm on the left walk way
okay
like this oh shit oh I got it I got it I got oh wait wait now what do
you
that's my stream but but then this comes up what do I do now
wrap around again and go back the right walk way and go back to the right
okay I'm back on the right go to the middle
go to the side where the fence isn't
wrap the pull it is wrapped did I wrap it wrong should I wrap it like this
is that the right way to wrap it
got a wrapper on the second one oh okay okay okay okay okay I'm getting it I get it
wait what wait
what
you got me fucked up someone's trolling me here
you were doing it right the first time
you're close when you had both wrapped I can't get them okay I got now they're both now they're
both wrapped let's go
I did it
did I do it
let's go oh yeah also I forgot to say someone sent me a tip last last stream uh thank you I don't
have tips set up yet I don't have them set up to show but I did see it after stream so thank you
very much I need to set that up for next stream I forgot actually no next stream is ASMR so I can't
have that one oh good girl thank you thank you thank you okay okay okay I think that's everything here
right oh okay next thing next thing okay oh my god I couldn't do it without your help thank you
oh
every time the game lags I'm scared something
her voice is so sexy
spin my mouth mommy
that
I'm ready
the game station is still working it will be just like old times just like old times
you're going to have so much fun head to musical memory and mommy will get things started
obey the rules or I'll tear you apart and eat your insides while you're still alive
god she's so hot
fuck eat my insides please oh I can go okay
oh my god can you tell what why I like horror games it's not because I like getting scared
let's just say that okay oh god look at this one this one's like bleeding from his eyes
that's not collectible wait isn't that one of the monsters
she took my fucking arm too
mama
mama that's not what you're supposed to sound like
she said something about um challenges right there's a collectible in the yellow tub in the
playground right yellow tub yellow tub I was raining outside I did see there was a thunderstorm
there was a thunderstorm warning um sorry if you hear the rain yellow tub
she's holding your hand oh you're right she took my hand to hold it because she loves me so much
I don't see it
shut the fuck up she makes you go from two inches to 2.5 inches she makes me go
from two inches to three inches at least okay I am a grower
there's so many drawings here oh huggy and kissy oh is her name kissy
where's the yellow the yellow the yellow um
where where's the pool kissy missy oh I thought her name was like mommy long legs or something
press here
choo choo
welcome to the
why does it work oh my god
I am so crazy strong and smart
musical memory
musical memory okay I'm really bad at listening to games when they told me instructions
um oh there's musical memory thank you for holding my hand game
let's party oh wait which
yellow tube not tub oh yellow tube well okay let me go try to get the collectible
we'll make you smart thank you little by little you'll train me to be smart right
yellow tube oh there's a yellow tube okay let me get the yellow tube is there supposed to be
music during this part of the uh yep
are you drilling me
not the long one
is there a short tube
is there is there another tube here
oh this one
this tube this is a yellow tube there's nothing in the tube though up in the treehouse
um here
there's like multiple things that could be considered a treehouse clicker training
stop that's kind of hot stop don't say that don't say that right now
there's another tube here oh here it is okay I got it thank you
oh look there's stuff up there okay let's go back to the the musical memory
I keep hearing the tink of a plate what are you eating oh I'm not I'm not eating anything
oh you're hearing this that's my that's my straw I have I use a metal straw against them
um against uh a cup that's what you're hearing
now you get a new glove the next collectible oh when you get a new glove the next collectible
is easy to get okay okay
and that fog must be close oh yeah we're real close I'm the one that helped him you know make
his theory of uh his dog theory yep I was there I'm the one that inspired it his dog drilling
theory what's it called give it to me mama and give it to me am I supposed to be doing this
this and it over I know your birthday
I know when your birthday is June 28th June 28th
yeah classical condition theory is that what it is
where he like he like rings a bell or something um and then feeds the dogs and then whenever he
rings the bell the dogs just start to drill automatically something like that oh all right I
guess we're going this way have lost dogs oh fuck it's so dark turn the lights on
molding room
Amy wants peblos tongue ew no have you seen what all those freaking philosophers slash
old scientists look like I don't want any of their dogs
um am I in the right room what is that third button
stop oh there's some light all right there we go now we got some light
oh my god are we going to make another toy
what
oh
don't say anything about filling that up don't say anything about that no it gets
it gets liquefied too
you're such a perfect human subject to test peblos theory anyways we don't need a dog oh my god
I'm not gonna bark for you I won't do it
you can't make me I think that's next thing
oh now it's not it's getting drained what about for head pass that's okay I can take some head pads
for a cookie I won't bark for nothing
oh oh hands another hand
is that container Emmy no no it's not I guess next thing next thing this one
I guess we're making hands for ourselves okay
was that it
oh do I have to do this multiple times
am I doing something wrong would you bark for sheebie if she asked me too nicely I might
this is no painted machine oh what's this
oh okay okay um do I need to put paint in the machine
um okay I'll maybe up here wrong wrong direction let's go find some paint
she bees a dime she doesn't ask if she commanded me to bark for her I might just do it
do I put my goo in here for the paint
nope do I go in here
oh that's paint right oh and I probably put it in here right
no no
do
she be are you still here I have a favorite to ask I think she'd be left I have the goo where do I
put it though where do I put my goo
you can just pay with my blood I'll give it willingly
did I spill it put it in here oh there we go okay now it's got paint okay okay okay
okay I'm so smart look at me go I'm zooming through this level holy
shit it's all because of you it's all because of you I would have been stuck a long time ago
thank you for holding my hand okay now I have now I have my hands made give me one
give me one to put on my hands give it to me oh give it to me
okay do I do I not just take one mix your goo with ours
oh my god that just reminds me of the fucking Baku Deku Slime Baku Deku Slime Baku Deku Slime
so fucking annoying E or F oh there we go wait what does F do okay okay okay
okay oh there's another there's another okay okay okay
I can't do that voice okay um
am I done here green tape on the control pad green tape this is the control pad
okay okay okay and put it in put it in there we go yay another movie time
now that's always so loud
to temporarily hold electricity electricity charge lasts for 10 seconds
after 10 seconds the charge runs out
to mention this sound track when holding electricity shot shoot green hand receivers
mm to temporarily power other systems mm they are on the same timer lack of caution
may result in injury I feel like I've heard this soundtrack in like tick tocks
um use your grab pack responsibly
Baku Deku Slime I'll catch on I can feel you inside of me okay do I can I go now
shut up nerd
before you leave go upstairs okay cute face thank you why do they let me go in here is
there something in here I don't look maybe it's just through the looks
bio shock music I've never played bio shock it's a collectible oh there's a collectible up here
um
those waves gave me a never fading brain rot I know me too that's why I keep saying it
oh my god damn if only fun libism was here I could have found oh
oh um how do I run again
oh there we go I got it yay oh okay thank you for telling me about that okay how do I leave
out this hole no this is the hole I came out of yeah I didn't even need help to find that one
I found that one by myself um you need to power up the hand oh
oh
oh ah okay
oh shit
I'm getting PTSD from from stuff like this
oh my god I hear thunder outside
thank green oh
stop calling me a good girl oh my god you're gonna fucking
you're gonna make me noot before I even get to be chased by mommy
whoa oh I remember this
this
welcome to musical memory Jesus Christ the sound in this game is so
fucking badly
memory and cognitive recognition test is designed to stimulate several segments of the brain
allowing us to see how quickly and efficiently your brain works
like I put the sound so low and it's still so loud why is the sound like that is there
another sound option why does it do that memory time this isn't gonna go out
a sequence of colors will be shown and you must recreate the exact sequence using the buttons
around you uh-huh bunzo will slowly lower towards you when you complete a color pattern correctly
bunzo will rise back up when you input a pattern incorrectly bunzo will lower towards you faster
if bunzo reaches you your test is over the test will become more difficult as it continues
with longer patterns in quicker succession that's all good luck okay
isn't it amazing mommy hasn't seen the place I've been running in years mommy can only imagine
how excited bunzo must be it's been such a long time oh my god oh bunzo
hey we haven't even started the game now come on slow down now
let's not get too excited
good luck
where's the oh okay green
blue
oh
okay green blue
wow green blue red green blue red
blue blue red yellow green blue red yellow
green blue red yellow blue
was that it that was so quick all round two wait round two
red red yellow
red yellow blue
I'm scared
red
yellow blue green red
red yellow blue green red violet
okay come on now suck my cock violet round three wait what
red
violet red blue white
violet red blue white red
orange
which one's fucking orange they look the same
oh my god
okay
The name or it's no, the name or it's no, fine, the name or it's no, fine, thank you.
Wait, wait!
Oh, come on.
Come on!
Fuck me.
Olive brown.
That's no fun.
Oh, there you are.
Thank you, mommy.
Thank you.
You praised me too much, I don't deserve it.
You're too nice.
Okay.
We did good, that was really scary.
That had me really, oh, oh, oh, okay.
I knew you could do it.
I'm not used to this much racing, oh my god.
This way?
Let me in!
I expected you to fail, are you serious?
No, actually, never mind, you don't praise me enough, keep praising me, come on.
I believed in you, thank you.
That's what I want to hear, expected me to fail.
I never fail.
I don't fail at anything ever.
I love you and me, I love you too.
Oh, am I just supposed to jump down?
Um, okay.
I knew you could do it.
Stop you're making me fucking laugh like a fucking mouse, it's so annoying.
Okay, what do I do here?
Oh, there's a long neck toy, and it's covered in wood.
Rejected item, orange robot toy, reasons for rejection.
After considering both options, management has decided to go with mommy long legs as playtime-coast stretch toy concept.
I like him personally.
Orange robot toy.
Ah!
I'm guessing there's something, did you notice, did you all notice the scream of Bunzo's death?
No, he died?
I can't handle all these praises and compliments, it's- it's, it's- I can't- I can't focus.
Oh god, that's terrifying.
Oh! Oh, um, oh, lever.
I'm guessing I'm supposed to power something here.
What am I supposed to power?
You weren't scared during any of that last mini-game, but got spooked by random collisions on the ground.
Well, because I was, you know, I was expecting it to be scary. It was the scary part of the game.
So obviously, you know, I'm locked in.
What am I supposed to do with this?
Stop praising me and help me with the game!
Oh.
Oh, look, there's a huggy.
Get the crane to get the collectible.
The crane.
The crane. There was a crane around here. You're right, there was a crane.
Of course it's unexpected scares that get me.
Where is, oh here, the crane. So do I power the crane?
With this hand?
Is there like a button to power? Oh, there's another rejected one.
Kick me, Paul. Nobody likes it.
Laughed out of presentation.
He's just like me. I never told you. I want to tell you this story because it's really funny.
Okay.
Raise equals awkward in me.
The claw. Pull the crane over top of large objects to pick them up.
Oh.
Oh, this one. Pick this one up.
Pick it up. Do your job.
Pick it up. Oh, I have to, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I have to, I have to, um, the, the, the electrocute, right?
Okay, let me tell you the story.
So when I was like in seventh grade, maybe I used to play this very,
I used to play this very role-playing game. It was called, um,
it was called Feral Heart. If anyone, if, if anyone knows that game,
I'm going to be super fucking surprised. It was not a popular game, but okay, pick it up.
Pick it up. And, um, I used to role-play in that like all the time.
Give it to me now. Give it to me.
Oh, suck my, huh?
Was I supposed to move it so that it fell underneath me?
No, it was, um, it was a very role-playing game, but you could only be a wolf or a lion,
and I was usually role-playing as a wolf. You can make your own wolf or lion character.
When I, you could like customize the lion to look like a cat more,
and a lot of people did that so that way they could, so that way they could play as, um, please fall.
Okay, thank you. A lot of people did that so they could play as warrior cats,
and I played a little bit as warrior cats too.
Um, like I would make my own warrior cats, I see, and then I would role-play as one,
but that's not the point of the story. The point of the story is to tell you there was this one,
there was this one part of the map where people would do something called like the mating circle.
It doesn't, it doesn't sound like what you think it is, okay?
Oh, there's another rejected one. Hold on.
Serpup's a lot. Extremely negative reception from various focus groups.
Whoever's idea this was should feel ashamed.
So there was this one part of the map where they would do some activity, some event, I guess,
called the mating circle.
Now the mating circle, what happens in the mating circle is not a gang bang, right?
It's not a gang bang. What happens is, you know, everyone kind of gets in a circle,
and there's like, um, there's like a, um, there's like a ringleader in the middle of the circle, right?
Work!
What?
It's not an orgy! I know it sounds like one.
There's like a ringleader in the middle of the circle, and what they do, what they would do is they would, um...
Is there another sign?
A scientific?
A scientific sign.
Is they would call your name, like your username, and you would walk to the middle of the circle and sit next to them, right?
And then, basically how it worked is anyone, any other wolf that was interested in you and wanted to be your mate
be their mate in between a ladder where junk is piled and um or if like multiple people went
into the circle with you then you could choose like which one you wanted to be your mate or you
could reject them both so the point of this story is to tell you that anytime it was my turn I would
sit in these circles for hours by the way absolute hours to wait until it was my turn to see if I
to see if I could catch a mate in this free role playing game and every single fucking time it was
my turn no one ever went into the circle to be my mate I only ever got one mate
and I don't remember how it happened I think it was just some I think it was a girl I think it was
a girl she just came up to me she was like wow she had like a male character and she was like wow
you're so you're so pretty and I was like oh is this my chance to get to get a mate finally
and then um we like role played for a little bit together and then she left me like I added her
as a friend on that account and I found her because you can have different characters on the same
account and I found her later again by accident because she never came to me or found me or talked
to me ever again I just found her by by accident and it was a girl like character and I was like oh
my god I've been fucking bamboozled I've been bamboozled I actually didn't find a mate
that's okay to me that's why you have big brother you're gonna heal my trauma from being rejected
in the furry role play game okay now actually help me I'm I'm done I'm done with my my traumatic
childhood story something about a ladder right
yeah she one night stood me in catfish me you're right that fucking bitch
the lever the lever go down the stairs and move forward oh okay
down the stairs move forward climb this ladder
in the pile of ladders and blocks is the tap you want tap I want
the tape
oh oh oh oh tape tape tape okay okay okay got it I didn't see that it was a tape
I couldn't tell another one
well it finally happened after years of being ignored the company actually heard all my complaints
yep they listened to them very carefully I guess my words must have really inspired me to take action
because the next day I got demoted down to the great island of mr. toy
why do I talk to myself
okay sir poops a lot can I pull it yet no
I can't focus all I see is good girl in me over and over again
weight capacity reached
you call me fat take it
is it because of this
move how about now
um
pick up the dino with the crane and move him away from the square floor
the last time I did it didn't work see
what would I know way it it doesn't work though
I skipped this part in playthroughs different try different ankles
um I don't think that's the case
is this supposed to work
uh oh pull the claw away
try moving the crane and then put it back over the dino
it's supposed to work uh oh are you sure we didn't forget about anything
maybe I'll do it from far away
position it over the body
is that better
did you break the crane when you were getting the collectible
did I please don't please tell me I didn't
rotate the claw
up
are you fucking kidding me can you press the red button again
this part is a bit buggy sometimes
you gotta be shitting me I I don't deserve this I've been doing so good okay um
oh my god
maybe try press the button then the crane
okay um
it doesn't work at all
drag something up to the dino and jump on it maybe you'll be able to skip this part
could I save and reload
should I try that are you sure I didn't forget anything
okay I'll try to save and reload
wait can I not save is this is it already saved
it has autosave at checkpoints
okay
load the last autosave
watch your fucking put me at the start I swear
okay so this is where when when we first um
when we first loaded in right
so what
pull did I forget something should I should I should did I forget something
okay
maybe I have to press press this again or pull on this there we go okay
now it should work
there we go okay I'm so smart do the dino part first then get the collectible
the collectible is not there anymore
oops oops oops oops oops
wait where's my hand
okay please work
wait does he talk too
yeah
put a red heart if you want me to eat the spicy chicken
and put a blue heart if you want me to eat the regular chicken and put a black heart if you
want me to kill myself okay whatever
I better not see any fucking black hearts
am I oh okay
oh come on
oh
we did it we did it
hey mods band the one that put the black heart guys come on
come on
sorry I got distracted
okay there we go
beam me up daddy
so do I just ignore everything else here
I keep seeing black hearts getting deleted it's kind of funny I feel like there was so much in
that room that I didn't that I didn't do hi
why do I keep hearing thumps
I'll not this again
oh oh oh okay
um
wait what
hey what's the white heart for come heart
um
you need to get on top and then hit the one I'm on top
and then and then hit this one
um oh reverse of black heart uh that's nice
wait do I
when you're on top hit hit again
get up top and intentionally let go
get on top that's something you'll
ah wait okay
that's something I don't hear too often to get on top you said intentionally let go
let go when you're on top okay I'm gonna let go now
it didn't work
go up let go and grab the blue again get on top and hit it again
go up
when you are not on the leveling platform
oh god I'm confused wrap around the higher one first and wrap around the bottom one
but I can't get to the top one
I can't get to it stay on top grab the electricity when you're on top
oh
step one get on top okay step by step please step by step okay
okay I'm on top grab the electric pole
oh like this
oh oh oh okay okay okay okay okay okay I got it I did it wait oh okay nevermind I don't even need to
me huh
huh
do I have to just do this again what the fuck I was just on top why didn't you raise get up
go up okay god I'm I'm losing my mind right now
uh oh I just lagged the game just lagged uh oh
fuck you
why does this why does this place feel familiar I feel like
chair won't stop me from getting in there move over
flimsy chair oh we're back here can I open this now
hello hello someone someone gooned all over here am I done in here
wait let me reach
am I done
go back to where the lovers were oh okay okay okay oh we finished it how long is chapter two I kind
of want to finish all of chapter two but if it's really long maybe I won't be able to especially
when I'm this fucking stupid
let me make it louder
okay
my big brother
thank you mommy
no she didn't
wacko lucky wacko lucky wacko lucky wacko lucky okay okay okay okay
wacko lucky say that ten times fast wacko lucky wacko lucky wacko lucky
wac-a-woogie, wac-a-woogie, wac-a-woogie, wac-a-woogie.
Wac-a-moble-woogie.
Oh, okay, I remember this.
I remember this.
Okay.
Yay another move.
Welcome to Wac-a-woogie.
This advanced test is designed to assess the extent of your reactionary abilities.
A dual-palm grab pack will be provided to you for this test
Around you are 18
An adorable huggy look toy could appear out of any one of these holes
I'm gonna suck on one of those one comes out hit it with your grab pack
That's all good luck, okay
I
Yeah, cough drop that's what it's called
Wait both hands no, just one right? I was inch I
Wish I was
There's no none of them are out. Oh fuck. Oh, okay
Where is it?
Where is it? I didn't see any
Well, oh
Oh, it's really hard to see oh
My god, that's so scary
Okay, they're pretty slow
Why is the audio quiet it's quiet for me too
Is
It's supposed to be this quiet probably like to make it harder, right?
Shit, I don't see any more where are they
Stop stop. Oh my god, stop, please stop. This is scary. I don't like it
Where is it? Oh my god. Oh my god. Stop. Stop
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, there's so many
Why do I feel like I'm failing? Why do I feel like I'm doing really bad at this game?
Come on get out of my fucking holes
Oh
That was really scary
Wait, wait, wait, no, I'm not ready. I'm not ready. I'm not ready. I'm not ready to call again. I'm not ready. I need to take a break
Wait, maybe I should turn my sound up so I can hear them better. Was I close?
Was I close to being done?
You're tears are my nourishment
You're only using one hand it will be slow once the pace picks up use both hands to hit faster
Okay, let me
Let me try putting those sound up more. Maybe
Maybe that would help
I feel like the sounds in this game used to have strings attached to them
So they could be pulled back when they got too close to the children
Have fun
I
Should I
You can only do so much with money brightness is already up in the game is to start that's what I'm saying
I
Don't see any I don't see any should I put
Where is it it's coming from everywhere around me
I
Where is it I can't the sound is so confusing die
Oh
Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Stop?
I'm crying
I
Jump off jump off that edge come over here
Wait, I want to see if putting my brightness lower might help because maybe maybe it's too light
Um, that's a bad idea
Don't cry I'm going to try to ignore this time. I just keep slowly looking around. Okay
I feel like the sound helps me see where it's coming from though
Oh
The gamma
That's not a thing here
There's no gamma is it vignette?
Don't stay in the middle if that doesn't help you
Okay
Camera is brightness remove bloom, okay
Sound can't help you it helps you
Sound can't help you see it helps you hear
I know but it helps it feel like I feel like it helps me tell which direction it's coming from if I can hear like
Which direction it is
So
I feel like I'm fucking hallucinating now
Like I feel like I'm genuinely hallucinating some of them
Like for real
Get away from me stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop stop
I don't think I'm gonna pass this one
I
I don't think I can pass it
Phone a friend who the fuck am I gonna call should I get into the freaking vc
I
Should I get into the vc with the other girls and see if anyone wants to be here with me for emotional support
Huh
Come on
I
Get it leave me alone
No!
Please, please, please, please, please, please!
Ah!
Please!
Please, please, please, please, please!
Where is it, where is it coming from?
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please!
Oh my God!
Oh, you did it.
Hooray!
Mommy is so proud of you.
Here, Mommy has another hint for you.
Huh?
Fuck you, Mommy!
Give me, give me!
Yes!
Playtime Coltrane Access Instructions.
This information is recertified.
Playtime coins.
Icons must be sequenced in this exact order.
Thank you.
Thank you for praising me.
What's the rest of this stuff?
What's this for?
Did we ever use this?
This is part two.
Are we collecting this whole page?
Is this part one?
Mommy, one game left to play.
Sad.
Mommy was hoping you'd stay here forever.
Though, it's never too late to change your mind.
I don't care about you anymore.
I don't want to be with you anymore.
Leave me alone, Mommy.
You're not hot anymore.
I don't care.
I don't care what your voice sounds like.
I don't like it.
I wish Amy would scream at me like that.
If you frustrate me this much, I might do it.
Oh, fuck.
What do I do here?
I don't think I can jump back, can I?
Collectible here.
Collectible.
Look up.
Up there?
Do I have to go higher?
Oh.
Am I allowed to say that I'm going to KYKMSonYouTube.com?
Is that allowed?
How do I do this?
Okay.
No?
Die.
Only in Minecraft?
You'll make me sad if you say that.
Okay, I'm only going to do it in Minecraft.
Well, I guess I have to enter then.
Move!
Can you make me proud if you say that?
Well, which one is it?
Can I say it or not?
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, was I supposed to go down there?
Wait, no, I feel like...
Rep collectible?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Too late.
Oops.
Okay.
I never mean it.
No, I would never mean it.
No.
YouTube, don't worry.
I don't actually mean it.
Oh, who's that?
Oh, it's...
Is that Huggy Wuggy?
Oh, I missed you.
That's not Huggy Wuggy.
Do it.
Pull it.
Yes.
Oh, fuck off!
Is she nice?
Oh, she is nice.
Well, how nice of her.
Okay, hold on.
Let me put the sounds back down now.
Because now they're too loud.
Okay.
She's on our side?
That's good.
What is this?
Oh, it's so light.
I wish I had Optifine so I could zoom in like in Minecraft.
She's teasing me?
I know.
I could tell.
Uh-oh.
Is my arm going to get stuck there?
Okay.
Huh?
In here?
What a nice girl.
She's so nice.
She's the only one that's been nice to me this whole time.
Other than you two, I guess.
What am I supposed to do up here?
Galvanized square steel?
Drop.
Do I just go up here?
No.
So don't blame me if you don't wish to take the route if you know what I mean.
Um.
I don't know.
Should I?
Should I try?
What am I doing wrong?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Was I supposed to take that with me?
Oh!
Yee!
I'm so surprised I didn't even need help for that one.
Okay.
And then I guess we just keep doing that, right?
Come closer.
You have to cross all the steel doors fast.
Got it, got it, got it.
Where do I get the...
Wait.
Oh, do I just get it from the same place?
Okay.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Give it back!
No!
Wait.
Okay.
Hello, sisters of genius.
Oh, I can just push it.
I am a genius.
I'm so smart for making it...
Heart corridor.
I'm so smart for making it all the way here.
All by myself with no help at all.
Okay.
Is that Jacksepticeye?
Oh, not at all, sir.
That's what I'd like to hear.
So, Marcus,
what happened?
You see,
I was in home for the day,
when my grandparents realized
that if we bloody wallowed in the cafeteria again...
His accent is so funny.
And that's when I see it.
Jacksepticeye.
So, what did you do?
Where is that from again?
I forgot.
When I just thought I'd nab the bloody york
and be on me merry way.
Double the mornin', do ya?
Well, laddies.
I'm reaching for the thing.
And the mob handled Jolton at all.
Had me scared stiff.
I thought I was the only one there.
So,
I took a peek beneath the gate,
and some massive bloody thing
was duthering about the bloody hallway.
Thing?
You're sure it wasn't a person?
Clearly, and we can skip school
and take care of her 3k birthday.
Of course, yeah.
I don't need school anymore.
I'm obviously smart enough
to just graduate right now.
I haven't a bloody nausea murder-wise,
but I wasn't human.
It wasn't human.
Besides me, obviously.
Is it bad that I can't tell the difference
between a Scottish and an Irish accent?
I didn't know that Strowney was Scottish.
Had a Scottish accent.
I thought she had an Irish one,
because they sound the same to me.
Don't tell her I said that.
Poor Jacks, but they see.
Is that it?
Oh, how am I supposed to get there?
I can't tell between Strowney and fruit,
and one is from Scotland,
and the other is from North England.
I feel like I'd be able to tell
between Strowney and fruit.
That's easy.
No, don't tell Strowney I thought she had an Irish.
Don't tell her I said that.
Do I?
I have no...
Get one charge.
Open gate.
Get other charge.
Place it at the end.
Grab the other charge.
Okay, you're putting too much trust in me there.
Where is the charge?
Charge?
What did that do?
What did it do?
Do I need to get all of them?
But it won't last long enough.
Just don't tell her you thought she was English.
No, I knew she was in British,
like British, British, like,
like, like, hello, mate.
Good luck.
This one?
Let's fucking go.
I didn't think I'd be able to do that.
I was so confused when you said it in chat.
I was like, what the fuck do you mean
get one charge and get the other charge?
How many charges are we catching here?
We're gonna get so many charges we'll end up in jail.
Okay, go.
Go, break it.
Break it for me.
Yeah.
Say bye to Barry now?
Do you mean Jacksepticeye?
I can't say Jacksepticeye.
No.
Well, it was a sacrifice I am willing to make.
Oh, okay.
Wait a minute.
I recognize this place.
Isn't mommy gonna come up from there?
No, maybe not.
Okay, never.
I just recognize it because we've been in here before.
Okay.
We did it.
Did we do it?
Oh, the card's name is Barry.
Oh, Barry the card.
Oh.
That was whack-a-wacky.
Oh, I did it.
I fucking did it.
I hope you had a fun day at the game station.
No, I didn't.
I'll start you the last one.
Thank you for all the pets.
All the pets.
Did you know that pet in French means fart?
Which way do I pull it?
Which way does it go?
Open.
Go to the middle of the train station.
The train station.
And look up.
This?
Oh, yippee.
Yay, thank you for the collectible.
Okay, now how do I open this?
Why is it beeping?
What a funny language.
So when you sharded, you petted yourself?
No.
Sharded out?
Is there a word for sharded in French?
We didn't learn that in class.
They didn't teach us, like,
I think someone asked for like,
18 plus French like ASMR,
but it's like, do you think
they teach us how to dirty talking French?
Of course, I don't know how to dirty talking French.
I don't even know how to say cock in French.
Close.
Close it.
Come on, we're trying to be safe.
All the safety regulations.
I'm going to fall off the train if I don't close it.
Oh, wait.
I don't know how to say cock in French.
Isn't that all French is?
Just dirty talking?
The teacher has failed me.
Louie nerd.
Won't be teacher fat, aw.
Bracket.
There's many ways to say cock in French.
Louie nerd.
La baguette.
Or maybe even le cock
if you're feeling spicy.
What about a stream learning to do it?
Who's going to teach me?
There's no website that teaches you how to dirty talking French.
Is there?
They're always talking dirty.
Okay, okay, train code.
Okay.
This thing, that thing, that thing, that thing.
This thing.
Google translate?
That sounds like a bad idea.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Are you doing something wrong?
You're not done.
Oh.
Collab with someone who speaks French?
Mmm.
Wait.
I think one of the people who did a watch along with us speaks French, right?
Is it para something?
Is she like native French?
Do the code.
It's too early for the train.
Well, how do I get down here now?
Because isn't this the next game?
Paras...
Is it Parasite?
Parasite?
Yeah, maybe we can do a collab with her and she can teach me how to speak French.
She can teach me how to dirty talking French.
Why won't this open?
Stand to the right of the door and pull.
Is it opening?
She didn't understand you when you spoke French on stream?
Oh, bruh, really?
Damn.
Well, I speak like very, um...
I don't, like I speak very English French, like...
The kind of French I speak is like,
it's like the French of kids who just went to French school all their life,
like haven't ever been to Quebec or France or anything, you know?
Like...
She'd be happy to do that?
Oh my god, maybe I should reach out to her.
Oh, okay, where does this go?
Oh, there.
Well, now that's distracted me.
If Ella's Canadian French and she's real French, she won't understand it.
Well, no, my...
It should still be understandable, though.
It's just not a good accent.
That's all.
Like, it's still completely understandable.
Otherwise, all of my teachers wouldn't be able to understand me,
because I had, like, actual French teachers.
Oh, come on.
Down here?
Puzzle time, y'all.
Gotta use my brain again.
Unfortunately.
Now what?
Wait, now what?
Did I use the wrong hand?
Think?
Okay, I used the wrong hand.
Okay.
I got this.
Fuck!
I'm gonna fucking kill myself in Minecraft!
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Please!
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
Did I do it?
I did it, right?
Okay.
No.
We're alone.
Hm?
Mm-mm.
Oh my god, I'm playing-
Ah!
Ahh!
Welcome to Statues.
Hi.
This advanced obstacle course is designed to test your physical endurance and strength.
The rules are simple.
The lights will turn off.
You can move through the obstacle course at this time.
However, when the lights turn on, you can look around but cannot move.
You may move again once the lights turn back off.
The lovable PJ Pugga-pillar will follow you.
If PJ reaches you, your test is over.
Oh my god, wait, no, no, no, no, no.
Good luck.
Wait, I'm not ready, I'm not ready.
Come on, I need to take a break.
I need to take a quick break.
I need to take a break.
I'm gonna go refill my water.
I'm gonna go pee.
I'll be right back, okay?
Oh my god.
You
Okay, I'm back.
You didn't hear me, shut up.
You didn't hear me, you didn't hear anything.
How was the piss? It was okay.
It was a normal piss.
I didn't look at the color.
Surprisingly, I actually didn't, um, bleed at all.
I didn't goo at all while I was scared.
That's really surprising.
Usually I do, especially when I sneeze.
What did she say?
I can't hear you, bitch, speak up.
Huh?
I didn't hear anything she said.
Oops.
Okay, now the sound is completely off.
What just happened?
Okay, there we go.
Got it.
What the f-
Wait, wait, wait.
How was it already?
What happened?
Do you bleed when you sneeze?
I do, I do, I do.
When the lights turn on, you have to stop.
You can't move during lights on.
Did you forget the rules?
Okay, okay.
You don't move in the light.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, please hold my hand, I'm scared.
Hold my sweaty fucking hand.
Oh, come on.
What are those circles?
Should I have grabbed the circles?
Tell me right now, tell me right now.
Please tell me right now, should I grab them?
Do I grab them or do I do-
Are they for him?
Yes?
Shit, shit, what?
No, no, no, yes, no.
I can't see, I can't see.
How do I run? How do I run?
Which one is it? Which one is it?
I forgot, I forgot which button, I forgot which button.
Not the hard tube? What do you mean?
Stop pressing F, what the fuck is that?
You're scaring me right now.
Which direction do I go?
Stop, stop saying it's over, stop.
Go to the right when you get out of the tube?
Wait, I don't get it.
Choose hard path, shut up about hard path.
You gotta tell me where I have to go, otherwise I don't know.
I know it moves when the lights are on.
Should I have gone in a different direction?
Should I go like this?
What did I do wrong?
What did I do wrong that time?
Tubes after the slide have difficulties above them.
Go to your left in the tubes.
I did not fucking move.
Those hoops are optional?
I stopped talking when the lights are on.
Okay, hold on, I need to pause to reach out.
You let go of the bar so it counts as you're moving.
Oh, so I should hold on to the bars.
You don't have to hang on the hoops.
The pugga pillar is chasing after you.
I know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
When the lights are on, yeah.
But aren't the hoops faster?
So, Amy, what you need to do is run faster than the monster.
Okay, thanks.
Go!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, okay, okay.
Come on!
I can't do this.
I can't take it.
Usually I love being told I can take it,
but this time I can't fucking take it.
You moved during lights on?
I'm trying so hard not to do that, but I...
I lost eye!
God damn it.
Where's the easy tube?
I will see it.
Oh, it's on the left?
Go!
There's the easy one.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I can't see.
Have you played red like green light?
You're treating me like I'm actually delusional,
like I'm actually stupid.
Like I have negative IQ.
Oh, shut up, she fell for the easy path.
Go right?
What do you mean go right?
The blinking window.
What about it, what about it? What do I do there?
What do I do with the blinking one, hold onto that?
Ahh!
Go, go, go, go.
Let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, let go, what do I do here?
What do I do here, what do I do here?
Help me!
What do I do? Is it gonna curl up? Is it gonna curl up? Is it gonna curl up?
Let me in! Let me in! Let me in! Let me in!
You're safe? Which hole? There's no hole!
There's no hole. Oh, there's a hole! Get me in the hole!
Oh? Oh, okay.
Bitch, she talks so, so low. Is it music or sounds? I can't hear you, girl.
It's still chasing me.
Did I just fucking die of fall damage?
I thought I had to do all of that all over again. I got so scared.
What do I do here?
Mommy, mommy, mommy, shut up. Oh my god. I'm so tired of hearing mommy.
I never want to hear the word mommy ever again.
How do I get out of here?
Look up at the end of the- yeah. Have you tried looking up?
What?
I like how crazy her voice gets, though. I really like this voice.
Keep needing to put her like louder. She's so fucking quiet.
Where are you?
Up again?
Oh my god.
Okay, okay. I'm guessing I have to look up another time, too.
Oh, maybe go down here.
Look up simulator.
Look up stupid.
I am authorized. I am authorized.
She's about to turn.
Is my little sis winning? Fuck yeah, she is.
I'm winning so hard right now.
Right? Right?
Tell me I'm winning. Tell me I'm doing a really good job.
Do I turn this? No, okay.
Okay, now it's too loud.
Wait.
Oh, another cassette.
You know, some people think I'm really old.
I'm really old, no, no one fucking thinks I'm really old.
Some people think I'm really young, but I was actually...
I was actually listening and watching cassettes when I was younger.
A lot.
I had a whole cassette player and I had a whole collection of cassettes,
and I would watch cassettes.
I'm not that young.
You're doing a really good job.
I'm actually secretly a boomer, and no one will ever know.
Hag! No, no, I didn't tell you that so you couldn't call me a hag.
Give it to me.
Rotate top degree. Oh, wait.
What?
Oh.
There's a tape. Where is the tape?
Did I miss it? Probably. Is there somebody here?
200-year-old.
Oh, wait, no, where's the tape? Yeah.
There's nothing back here.
Oh, that's where we came from.
Literally legal.
How could you miss? It was three feet in front of you.
What was in front of me?
The tape?
There's no tape.
It was right...
Where? Here?
Oh!
Can I jump?
Oh, no.
Yeah, I was too distracted thinking about hags and how sexy...
Oh, okay. I was trying to read it upside down.
Okay.
I see.
No, no, no.
Wait, no.
Wait, there's a top and a bottom?
This one.
No! Oh, that's the top.
Can I go the other direction?
Maybe like that?
Wait, what?
I don't get it!
No matter how old you are for me, you're eternally 19?
Why 19? That's such a random age.
Toy scanner.
Scan this toy.
Scan my dick.
I'm guessing I can't jump.
Can I? Should I try again?
19?
Haggler!
Watch out, we got an old lady over here.
She might trip and fall and hurt her back at 19 years old.
Can I grab it with my hands?
Sometimes...
Wait, so if I only rotate the top,
the bottom doesn't rotate, right?
Is that it?
But if I rotate the bottom,
then they both rotate, right?
Right?
Oh fuck you!
These bitches know what they're doing.
Wait, oh, oh wait.
Wait, wait, what?
No, I don't think I... I don't...
I don't think I got it.
So I need...
What?
Oh.
This fucking game is playing with my head.
But how am I supposed to get to it?
How am I supposed to get to it?
This is your first time seeing someone get stuck.
We'll be taking a lot of each other's first times.
Just keep trying.
Run while your hand is on it?
What do you mean?
Rotate more.
You gotta flip it truly.
You gotta use more specific language.
Step one, stand on blue platform in the middle.
Oh wait, I can't even get to it, hold on.
Okay, I'm in the middle.
I'm in the middle.
Can I just...
You know what, I don't even deserve that.
I don't deserve to see that fucking cassette.
I'm too fucking stupid.
Oops, am I tracking?
I don't deserve to even look at it.
I don't know how I got this far in life.
How haven't I died yet?
Watch me not be able to get it anymore.
Oops, I think I did it.
I'm trying to finish this fucking chapter,
but it's really taken my soul with it.
Play.
This better be fucking worth it.
Should I know this guy?
Is he also like a popular gamer?
It's huge, I'm telling you. What's your favorite color? Blue? I bet it's blue, right? It's blue?
It's green.
Okay, well, your special case, most people would say blue.
But seriously, marketing is not as easy as you think.
I make it look easy.
If there's anything playtime coach should be known for, it's not toys, it's marketing.
Thank you.
Your special case?
A special nutcase.
What do I do now?
I'm guessing I go to one of the places.
What the hell is the E sound?
Benjamin?
Am I supposed to, is Benjamin like a YouTuber?
Go to left first.
Wait.
Oops, wait, no.
Aw, fuck.
Now I'm going to have to figure out how to get to the left one.
No, I wasn't listening to the video, was I supposed to? Was it telling me something important?
Hitting that Benjamin to blinker tint.
What the fuck kind of zoomer talk are you, are you saying?
Oh!
What?
Oh.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, but...
Oh!
What?
Oh.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, but...
Wait, what?
Oh!
Can you meow like her?
What did she say?
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
Button.
Oh.
When you elevate yourself, go all the way to the top and grab the button.
Oh, I did it!
Did something happen?
Oh, this one's to go down.
Ugh.
Okay.
Oh.
Is there anything else?
Am I missing something?
Should I press the other buttons?
Aw, I think I'm doing something wrong.
I'll never understand why viewers urge humans to get collectibles.
They'll never worry or care about.
I don't know, it's fun.
It's a nice challenge, even though this entire fucking game is hella challenging for me.
Okay.
So...
I feel like...
I feel like I should be sending these arrows a specific direction.
Can I go up here?
You're doing it correctly?
Which way are they supposed to go?
We direct the cat to a sand.
You should be sending them towards you.
Where is me?
Where am I?
Which cat?
Are those cats?
Those look like monkeys.
How late is it?
I tell you how late it is, you're going to make fun of me for yawning.
Those are the bunnies.
There's no cats here.
Okay.
Okay, so I have to make them come towards me.
So, if they go that direction...
They go there.
Oh, but then they fall.
I won't, I promise.
Thank you, promise.
What do you hear inside me?
I don't know.
Do you want to find out?
Go up and hit the next one.
Push the blue button.
Oh, can I reset?
Yeah, everyone was thinking it.
He just said it.
He said it for everyone.
Oh, did I do it?
Oh, no, I didn't.
There we go.
Hello.
Now what?
I'm squishy and warm on the inside.
Okay.
Is that all I needed?
Proof?
Proof where it didn't happen.
Bring it back to the other side of the spinny platform.
The spinny platform.
Is there a spinny platform?
Oh, that goes up.
Okay.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, nobody leaves without a toy.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
The toy scanner.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Here we go again.
I need that one.
I can't believe the NSFW Twitter was official.
What do you mean?
Do you not know anything about us as streamers at all?
I'm not as streamers.
I guess as a company.
What time is it?
It's 8pm.
Yippee.
I've highly educated myself.
Listen, I've had a stressful evening here.
Of course, I'm going to be tired.
Okay.
On the whole.
The V-Sack.
Wait, what?
Was I here before?
No, I guess not.
What?
Okay, I'm glad no one made fun of me for being tired at 8.
What do I do here?
This part is tricky.
Okay, will I go another direction then?
I'm tired the moment I wake up.
Me too.
That is very real.
Oh, this is a different place.
Wait, no, it's not.
No, wait, yes it is.
Okay.
Wait, oh no, I need...
Oh, I almost fell down.
Okay.
Are you fucking shitting me?
Wait, what?
Hold on.
Oh.
I thought I was gonna...
Okay.
I had a little bit of a delay reaction.
Excuse me.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, I'm gonna...
Huh?
Why did you lock it?
What?
Oh.
Wait, no, don't use that hand, don't use that hand.
Okay.
Ah.
What?
Sorry, sorry.
It's still locked though.
In order to get the red tape,
you need to touch the second electric pole.
The second electric pole.
Do I go back this way?
Okay.
When we can hear you smile when you talk, that's the cutest shit.
Can you hear me smile?
I think it's mostly that you can see me smile.
Further from the panel.
Panel.
What is a panel?
There's a panel here?
Hello?
Did I fuck it up?
Uh-oh.
You can hear me smile?
Aww.
Step one, grab one.
I grabbed one.
You have to activate the other room
and then go back with your hand still connected.
Touch only the further pole.
Oops.
Okay, only the further pole.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Okay, okay.
Wait, what?
Hold on.
What just happened?
What?
Wait.
The circle in the middle of the screen
indicates how far your arm...
Oh, there was a circle.
Wait, I feel like I just did nothing.
What did I...?
Wait.
What did I just do?
That was nothing.
Did I...
Your smile sounds like ara ara, what the fuck?
How is that...
What?
What did I...
What did I forget?
Stop.
When you type in me like that,
it makes me feel like you're disappointed in me.
Where do I go now?
Red door was open.
It was open, you're right.
It was open.
What do I do with it?
Come on.
Repeat the steps.
You did great, just forgot to send energy
to the one in the wall.
Don't use my full government name against me.
Or there was...
Was there another one here?
Am I missing something?
Stop!
If you see channel VR,
grab the red tape tucked into the electrical panel.
The red tape tucked into the electrical panel.
Okay, the red tape tucked into the electrical panel.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, behind me?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, now I feel like I'm going the wrong direction.
Okay.
Electrical panel.
Oh my fucking god.
The way they make me kill myself here?
It's like...
It's like extra punishment.
Okay.
You can die later.
Kill me now, please.
I don't want to.
You've tortured me enough.
Get your...
Pull yourself back up, soldier.
Okay.
Oh!
How am I supposed to see that?
How is...
Okay, wait.
Oh, this one.
Am I supposed to keep my hand there?
Okay.
Oh, that's the wrong thing there.
Is he talking about...
Is he talking about mommy?
I am a good girl.
I'm a good girl for suffering through this game with you.
Okay, where do I go now?
You can pick all the bookers with that thing.
Yeah, he is.
Okay, okay.
Do I leave?
That's not...
Spiders aren't scary, I agree.
I have a spider.
Her name is Rangel,
and she's a tarantula.
And she's an Arizona blonde,
and she's five years old,
and she's really fat.
You gotta do it again and go through the other door.
The best girl?
Your best girl?
No.
You have to need to get through the electrical door.
Electrical door.
There's another door.
Okay, I'm gonna go here.
Another door.
This door?
Jumping spiders are really cute.
Is it this door?
What's the point of using both of these?
What if I just do one?
Nothing.
In the room with the TV.
The other outlet.
Did you try to type in me,
and instead of correct it to I'm my?
Right there, the circle.
The circle in front of me.
The circle, the circle in front of me.
It's just that simple, the circle in front of me, right.
Why don't I think about that circle in front of me?
Yeah, but yeah, I get it.
Yeah, the circle in front of me.
The circle in front of me.
All these squares make a circle, and I'm in the middle, and all the rest of the wolves
are around me, and no one wants to be my mate, and I'm getting publicly humiliated because
no one wants to be my mate!
I don't need sleep, I need to finish this fucking level, that's what I need!
Okay, fine, jeez, let's go up left, tell me what to do now?
Look for the number 2 in the room with the VCR.
Your circle is your reticle, are you?
Are you shitting on my dick right now?
Swing across, open door, swing back, connect power.
Swing across, you gotta connect 1 to 2.
Okay, what?
I should be in front of the...
When you open the door, don't take the energy out of it.
Number 2?
2?
Any 2s?
Why won't it work?
Huh?
It's right there, it's right there!
What's going on, what's going on?
It's right there, it's right there, it's right there, just let me...
You have to swing back?
Huh?
What is a reticle, what does a reticle mean?
You have to swing back, you need the green one?
There's a green one?
Swing to the other room, then let go, then let go, left hand go through the door,
you will be back to the first, activate the pull, that doesn't...
You need green power.
Green power, of course!
Right, yeah, green power, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I need green power.
You gotta open the door to go through the red side to get the electricity.
Yeah, green power, yeah.
Why don't we go to sleep?
If I pass this, do I win?
Like how much more is there?
Do I need both of these?
In the middle of the screen you got a little rectangle.
No?
The lid?
I feel like...
Okay wait, so do I need both of these?
Hold on, I have an idea, I have an idea, I have an idea, let me do something here.
Let me do something.
What the fuck is this called?
Yeah, stand back, I'm starting to cook with gas now, okay?
What is this part? What should I call this part?
Come on, fucking ad.
Wait, is there such a thing as YouTube dark mode?
Okay, we passed that, we passed that.
Oh fuck, we're almost at three hours?
Okay, we passed that.
YouTube has a dark mode?
Oh this is the room, okay.
I want to finish this fucking game dude.
I'm not about to change the dark mode right now, let me have my fucking light mode.
I like light mode.
I know it's muted, I know it's muted.
Is he figuring it out himself currently? Does he not know how to play either?
Cause he looks like he doesn't know how to play either.
Come on dude, come on, this is a walkthrough, you're supposed to know what to do already, come on man.
Maybe he's talking?
No, he's not even talking.
Come on man, don't waste my time here, come on.
Oh my god, you dumbass.
Wait what?
Is this guy stupid?
Is he being stupid on purpose?
He's not talking.
Bro, this is not a walkthrough.
How are you going to fucking die during a walkthrough?
Yeah everyone's stupid except for me.
Come on, you can do it, come on.
Play it at two times speed.
Does he get stuck here too? Cause it looks like he's almost not...
Okay no, I'm not watching this, I'm not fucking watching this.
Give me a walkthrough.
Like show me that you know what you're doing.
Oh my fucking god.
This is so frustrating.
It's literally a pre-recorded video, cut out the parts where you fucking die.
Isn't that fucking hard? It's a walkthrough.
Walk me through the game, why are you showing me you dying?
Do you want me to copy that too? Do you want me to copy every time you fucking die?
Wait, what?
Wait, what just happened?
Let me look through that again.
Okay.
Oh you have to do it really quickly and you have to get both of them.
It stays open.
Okay.
Oh god it's lagging, why is it lagging?
Okay, hold on, let me...
God this game hurts to look at.
This developer should KYS.
One out, one out.
What do you mean gamma? Do I have something?
This play capture? Do I have like a filter on my...
Where's the gamma? What gamma are you talking about? There's no gamma.
The developer should kiss his sister.
Turn your brain around, do you hate it so much?
Like, huh?
Is that better? Is that what you want?
Thank you for the pet.
Okay, I'm as the same thing as Brainus, but I feel like this is too dark.
I'm really blind, man.
Okay.
Let me see what he does.
Where do you go? Back in here.
Okay, okay.
Nothing is brighter than your smile, oh you.
Nothing may be bright and OBS.
Like my display capture doesn't have any gamma filters or anything.
Yeah, of course I fucking love the dislike, are you kidding me?
What's the fucking effort into your walkthrough?
It's not that hard.
Wait, what?
The wrong direction?
If you could just watch the rest of the playthrough?
Okay, oh shit.
This is when mommy chases me.
Okay, if I get stuck here with mommy, I'm gonna...
I will end, right?
I asked you to play fair and you cheated.
Great cheaters.
What do I do? What do I do? What do I do?
One last game.
Okay.
Hide and...
Stay.
Fuck.
Ten.
Nine.
God, the way she goes crazy is so sexy.
I hate her before but her voice is so hot.
Am I actually supposed to hide?
I'll just run? Okay.
I'll just run.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
I feel like it's really suspiciously quiet.
Oh, come on now.
Did I go the wrong direction?
Okay, wait, I'm pausing.
What did I do wrong?
What did I do wrong this time?
Did I go the wrong direction?
Up?
Hello, you silent when I'm crazy?
You can go listen to me be crazy if you want.
There should be a handle.
Stop saying I'm mine.
Okay, look up where?
Look up where?
Where is the up?
You have to pull yourself off while she passes by.
I feel like I'm just walking towards her now.
Here?
Wait, what? Am I?
I think therefore I'm mine.
Go back?
Is there some sort of timer?
I was doing it right the first time?
Oh.
Okay, and now she's going to chase me through this?
Get back to me!
Okay, okay.
I feel like I should be getting chased right now.
There's no urgency here.
Should I do all of these?
Put the figure in a jiffy.
Put the figure in a jar.
There's an order.
I'm guessing it's...
Red, yellow, blue, green.
A common tactic in this game when stuck is to look up.
What do I do here now?
Wait, wasn't there a voltage thing?
Tab?
This one?
That's a train call.
Numbers?
Look under?
Numbers.
Numbers, what do they mean?
Numbers!
Okay, goodbye.
It's just the order of the numbers.
Numbers?
The wires? The numbers and the wires?
There's numbers and wires?
Numbers?
Pull up, check the numbers.
The numbers.
Two, one.
Is it one, three, two?
Is that the order?
There's numbers, yeah.
Look at the numbers on the boxes, yeah.
Let's tell you what color lover to pull.
So red, red, red, green, blue?
Red, blue, you guys are telling me different colors.
Red, red, blue, green.
Red, blue, green.
Did I do it?
Wait, red, blue, green, yellow.
Yellow, where's yellow?
There's no yellow.
Where are you seeing yellow?
Fucking, stop saying I'm mine!
Yellow last?
But there's no yellow here.
Okay, red, red, blue.
Oh, there is a yellow!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Red, red, blue, green, yellow, okay.
Okay, red, blue, green, yellow.
Yay!
Oh my god, I love not being stuck in video games.
Ah!
Where is she?
You built me.
I really wanna finish this chapter!
Okay, okay now I know that she's gonna show me.
My eyes, my eyes only on me.
My eyes only on me.
on me don't even worry about the game
hahahaha
wait I'm already halfway through?
no I'm not
am I safe?
You're super close okay okay okay I want to finish it I want to finish it I want to finish
it okay thank you for staying with me for so long and struggling with me and helping me
what's that oh is this the one where she falls in we kill her right move over I
gotta push her in get out of my way oh is it not the one where she falls in a few
more jokes and we're home free okay okay oh cool oh thank you for all the support
oh I can do it I can do it maintenance list can I get a TLDR oh man gear
well I have a gear can I put it back put that in the fire okay now use it put the
gear in the fire we need to go upstairs okay okay I did it and then do I turn the
fire on is that it I believe in I'm fine okay now do I push mommy in
I'm my supremacy there's nothing else to grab is there wait we came from that direction
we need to hide in the furnace do I go in the furnace while it's on fire what do you
mean I need to hide in the furnace oh another gear oh maybe I put this gear
somewhere probably it's a little work is it gonna work now pull the lever next to it
there we go okay now I like her on fire right right how do I like her on fire
though
go inside mommy go inside go and bite, go and bite, go inside, go inside
Huh?
Wait, I hide in the grass?
Um, um, um, um...
Hahahaha!
I can't!
I did it, I...
Hahahaha!
Task failed success!
Oh, where did she go?
Hahahaha!
I guess I can just go in there.
Yeah, even the game loves I'm.
Hahahaha!
I'm surprised she walked by me.
Okay, now she goes in the grass?
Yeah?
Hahahaha!
Oh, you gotta be kidding me.
Are you kidding me?
Run? I wasn't supposed to go through that door?
Freakin' barrels.
Hahahaha!
Okay.
She's not chasing me.
I need to go back to get her.
Hahahaha!
Okay.
I should have bare-loaded her!
Hahahaha!
What am I supposed to do here?
You did everything right now.
It's all about not making mistakes.
Right, yeah.
I know how to do.
I know how to not make mistakes.
Hahahaha!
Look up.
Is she chasing me?
Hahahaha!
This fucking barrel, dude!
Okay, what do I do here?
What do I do there?
I'm still confused.
Hahahaha!
Turn around?
Ohhhhh!
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Hahahaha!
Turn around, turn around, turn around, turn around!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Hahahaha!
Okay.
She didn't come yet.
Hahahaha!
Uh-uh.
Get cut.
I'm walking in the sewers right now.
Oh, fuck!
Let me turn the sound down a little.
Isn't he wonderful?
I'm still not excited for chapter three.
Okay.
Okay, I can do this. We're almost done.
Right, right, right, right, right. We're almost done after this.
This is it, right? This is like the last chase, right?
Please say yes. Please say yes. Say yes.
To me? Please say yes.
I feel like that bear was there on purpose, isn't it?
To fuck you over.
Laugh isn't really sexy anymore.
I don't want to play with you anymore. You're not sexy.
She legit sounds like she's painfully gagging on something.
Yeah, gagging on my dick!
It's not a skill issue. It's a game issue.
They just have to fix their aim.
The game obviously is poorly optimized here.
If they can't pick up my perfectly aimed mouse cursor.
Gagging on the two-way check.
Come on! Did I walk into her?
Shut up! There's so much to gag on it.
It'll go so deep in your throat just you fucking wait.
Cough.
Okay.
I'll do it this time.
Your throat will be so sore.
Your dentist is gonna be like,
God damn, were you gagging on a fucking...
I don't know.
Were you gagging on Amy's dick last night?
Because that's the only cock that would be long enough to make such...
such damage to your throat.
I got it that time!
I fucking got it that time!
Too slow.
The dentist knows?
Yeah, there's like bruising at the back of your throat sometimes.
The dentist will know.
I'll make sure that throat is bruised up, baby.
Fuck this barrel!
No!
Get up you fucker with my craft!
In my craft, in my craft, in my craft...
In my craft, in my craft, in my craft.
In my craft, in my craft, in my craft, in my craft.
In my craft, in game, in game, in game, in game, in game, in game,
In game, in game, I, I, I died in game.
I died in game.
My throat is literally killing me right now.
Oh.
Wait, I take a long time because I'm trying to.
I'm trying to ink correctly.
Oh my god.
Okay, if I don't get it this time, I'm literally stopping.
And we'll finish it the next time.
I can't.
We'll finish the next time.
I didn't even see it.
I had it and I didn't even know.
I didn't know what I was doing.
How do people do this?
This is like way harder than the first chapter.
What do I do?
Please tell me what to do.
Why is it so slow?
Oh, you gotta be kidding me.
Die, bitch! Die!
I love seeing you in pain!
That's right scream for me!
Oh my god.
Okay, we did it.
Right?
Thank you for the head pass.
Oh.
Is this it?
Please tell me.
That's it.
I know I'm so good at games.
Like, really, they should have considered that I might play this game and make it harder
because this was just too easy.
Hi, I fucking saved your life, bitch.
What?
Do I have to read that?
I can't read that.
Opening the control station.
Just pull both levers?
Oh.
Yeah, double fist that shit.
It's not working.
Slap, puppy?
Is that it?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm so happy!
Oh my god, that was such an emotional roller coaster.
Where am I going?
You skipped a tape?
I don't fucking care.
Was it important?
Was it really important?
That thing, that thing, that thing, that thing.
Do I press buttons?
I'm confused.
Do I press the buttons?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, I have to make them the right colors.
Wait.
So this thing is red?
Okay.
The other thing is yellow.
The next thing is red.
Okay.
The last thing is blue.
Oh wait.
Oh, now I have to put them in the right order.
Red, yellow, red, blue.
Now what?
It's in the right order.
Hit the arrow to put them in the same order.
Yeah, they're in the same order.
Yeah.
Red, yellow, red, blue.
The color.
I've seen subscribers break their brains on this puzzle.
You understood it immediately?
Password three?
One, four, two, three.
How do I change the numbers?
But how do I change them?
Push them?
Punch them?
I can't click on it.
Huh.
Click on the faces?
Oh.
One, four, two, three.
Go.
Let's go.
Let's leave this.
Oh, is it going?
Yippee.
Re-game.
Red lever's a break?
Oh, we don't want to break.
Choo-choo.
Can I go choo-choo?
Yay.
Choo-choo.
Oh my god, I'm so tired.
Let's go.
I ran out of water again.
Phew.
Get applauded.
Hm?
Ew.
Whoa.
What?
Sounds like me?
Time to figure out what's happening.
Hm?
I'm not good at copying voices like Chibi.
What?
Hm?
What happened?
Why is it going faster?
Where are we going?
Why are we going so fucking fast?
Are we tilting?
Are we getting tilted right now?
Get tilted.
I feel like something bad is going to happen.
Hm?
What do I do?
Do-do.
We're going to die.
Stop train.
I can't.
No brakes.
No brakes on the train.
It's not going to work.
My hand.
Don't rip my hand off.
Oh, that was it, wasn't it?
Playcare?
Never mind playcare.
I need some fucking aftercare after getting fucked in the ass so hard.
We did it.
Chapter 3 tomorrow?
No, I already have something planned for chapter 3.
I already have stuff planned for next week too.
Maybe the week after that we can do chapter 3.
There's Jacks but I see Big Spider.
Yeah, I did it.
I did it.
Is that it?
There's not like other-
Shut up.
It is not story early for another horror game.
I can't.
My mind is-
I've been mind broken.
What do you want as a reward?
A shower.
We can shower together as a reward.
A shower and a cough drop and some tea.
That's what I want as a reward.
Yeah, together.
Quit.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Now the chat has to cap up.
Cap up.
Check.
Check up.
Catch up.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you for coming.
I did it.
I usually-
I usually release stream too.
I'm fucking blinking like a fucking frog right now.
I usually only-
Okay, that's really distracting.
I usually only stream for two hours.
But I guess we were here for the long run.
Thank you so much for coming and staying
and helping me the whole time.
Encouraging me and praising me when I was going insane.
I'll see you tomorrow.
I have a lot planned for tomorrow.
I think it's going to be really funny and exciting.
Bye-bye.
I love you, big bro.